Você já ouviu falar do óleo essencial de
frankincense ele também é conhecido pelo
nome de olíbano é um óleo extraído da
resina da árvore bosua carteri muito
valorizado por suas propriedades
medicinais e aromáticas ele costuma ser
utilizado na aromaterapia para aliviar o
estresse porque possui um efeito
calmante e relaxante Esse óleo essencial
também tem propriedades
anti-inflamatórias e ansol o que
significa que pode reduzir a inflamação
no corpo e diminuir os níveis de
ansiedade Além disso seu aroma
amadeirado e levemente picante é
conhecido por acalmar a mente e ajudar a
equilibrar as emoções como você faz
então para utilizar esse óleo essencial
para tratar o estresse e a ansiedade uma
das formas mais populares é pela aroma
terapia que você pode fazer inalando o
óleo essencial ou usando ele através de
um difusor isso faz com que o aroma seja
espalhado do ambiente o que vai provocar
um efeito de
tranquilidade